- You have a seven year
old, I have a seven...
I have a five and seven
year old actually at home,
but you have a seven year old.
So how are you enjoying fatherhood?
Do you love it?
- I really do, I love it.
Because, it... this kid was
a blessing to God for me,
I'm telling you, because
we weren't expecting him,
he pops up and he is
everything that I was as a kid.
So every time I hug him,
every time I say I love you,
every time I'm correcting him,
or chastising him in love,
I'm healing myself in
some part of my childhood.
So it's so beautiful to have him
and he's such a great, great kid.
And we've kept him off social
media, kept him off of iPads,
all the other stuff, so that
he can find out who he is
before the world starts trying to tell him
that he's my son or he's somebody else.
- That's powerful.
- [Tyler] Yeah, yeah.
(audience applauds)
- We do this, I don't allow
my kids to have the...
I'm like, I'm sorry, you're
probably not gonna have it
while you're in my household.
I'm just like, 'cause it's scary.
- Because I watched it whenever I,
I was married, we had two older kids
and I watched these teenagers like,
be validated by likes or if
they didn't get likes they're,
"Oh, I guess I'll take this picture down."
I'm like, wait, what?
I'm like, don't let somebody, you know,
control like your power or
have your power like that.
- Like, it's a scary thing
and I think it's just still,
we haven't quite figured
it out until that happened.
Sorry, you're not getting it.
- Yeah, until the Congress steps in,
there's some sort of regulations
to what's happening right now,
I don't know if we're
ever gonna get better.
- I mean the bullying, the
suicide rates, like it's crazy.
Speaking of suicide rates,
I don't wanna bring the show down
but I am seeing things
I have never seen before
with people just committing suicide.
I'm like what is going on in the world?
But if you look at the state of the world
and everything that's happening,
people will start to think
that there's no hope,
but I'm here to tell you there is.
- Absolutely.
- There is tremendous hope.
(audience applauds and cheers)
You have to hold onto it.
Gotta hold onto it.
- Yeah, and it's how you filter your day
of what you're taking in.
- Yes, filter it, filter it.
- You know you should
read The Tipping Point
if you haven't already.
- I haven't, I haven't.
- It's really good, but it discusses...
Anyway, I'll talk about that later.
Um, anyway, but a lot of
people write into the show
with parenting questions,
so we thought that it might be fun
for Tyler and I to answer some of those.
Maybe we'll fail, we don't know.
Um, are you cool with it?
You don't have a choice.
- Okay, good.
(both laugh)
- I was just wondering if I'm gonna answer
as Tyler or Medea, but we'll
go ahead, we'll figure it out.
- You can... either one can answer.
- I'm excited at the
opportunity of either one.
Okay, so let's see the first one.
So, how do you deal with
having to watch (laughs)
the same movie or hear the
same song 27 times in a row?
- When your kid's very young,
how'd you deal with it?
- My kids still do it!
Five and seven, they still...
I've seen Encanto, I
love Encanto, luckily.
Thank you Encanto people.
But like it, but I
have... I can recite it.
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- Yep.
- And then we get in the
car and I'm not allowed to
play anything else other
than the soundtrack.
- And you... and you're okay?
- I'm okay, I can compartmentalize.
It's crazy.
- That's good that you
can compartmentalize
but I'm gonna tell you the answer.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Weed gummies.
(Kelly laughs)
Weed gummies.
(audience laughs and claps)
- [Tyler] I'm telling you every...
every time you see every it, every-
- Weed.
- Weed, weed.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- Every time you see it
you'll see something else and you go, wow.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
This movie is so deep!
- It's like watching O in Vegas,
you see something different every time,
there's so much happening
and you're like, "Wow".
- Wait, you like O too?
- [Kelly] I love O!
- Did you see it on a gummy?
- No, I didn't see it on a gummy.
- You like O, I love O,
we gotta get married.
We gotta get married, I'm telling you.
- But it is like, I feel like
you don't even have to be
on a gummy to see O, you
watch O and I'm like,
I missed that.
This whole section, like,
the last time I was here
was, 'cause there's so much happening.
- It's the most incredible
Cirque du Soleil show
I've ever seen.
Everybody that goes to Vegas,
I'm like, you've gotta see it.
- It's so good.
- It's really good, yeah.
- [Kelly] We're perfect together.
- Yeah.
So this one's a bit heavier.
The world seems to be
more and more polarized.
So what do you say to your kids
when they ask you why
no one can get along?
This has actually happened to me.
- [Tyler] Really?
- Yes, about homelessness.
My daughter's very
concerned about homelessness
and she's very concerned
about why people are fighting.
She doesn't understand.
- Especially when Black
Lives Matter was happening
and the pandemic and everything.
It's a very hard conversation to navigate,
what to share or not share yet.
- Yes, exactly.
Especially at an age where
they're so impressionable with everything.
So I've been very, very
careful to try to keep again,
not having iPads and
not watching television
and so, you know, monitoring what he sees
has really helped me to not have to
have that conversation yet.
But it's a really, really hard one,
especially for a black parent
with a little black boy.
- Yeah, it's hard for anybody
to explain to their kid,
you know, why it's been so bad, but-
- No, but I've had black
women on this show tell me,
it's hard for me to explain why
you should be nervous when
you get pulled over by cop.
- Why you should, I've
had these conversations.
I'm like, oh my God, I've
never had to think about that.
- Yeah, especially when,
when dad has been pulled over
and I was Tyler Perry at the time
and still had a horrible incident.
So it's a scary time but again,
my hope is that we're raising
people, we're raising kids
that will come up and
change this and buck all of
- [Kelly] Do better, yeah.
the foolishness, right?
- Yeah, because we've screwed up a lot.
So I'm hoping that this
generation that's coming up,
that we're giving them enough love
and compassion and teaching
them about humanity.
Not race, but humanity,
love for humanity, right?
(audience applauds)
And see if that helps.
- It's amazing what the kids are taught.
Like now that I'm a parent, it's amazing.
Like, I have a five and seven
year old, they don't know.
They don't even see that,
they're taught that.
And you don't realize it
because we haven't been
little in a long time, you know?
So, well, not that long,
but like just a minute.
(Tyler laughs)
- Just a minute.
- No but, um, but it's
interesting like how,
you know, it is up to us
like, 'cause we teach that.
You teach love, you teach hate.
Like, so it's a... oh, it's
a heavy burden sometimes.
I feel like, so responsible of like,
am I saying the right thing?
Am I doing the right thing?
It's very, I don't know.
- Let me give you some comfort.
Every parent who's a good
parent feels that way.
So you're in, you're in great company.
We're all trying to figure that out.
(crowd claps)
- Okay.
That did make me feel good, thank you.
Like, okay, we're gonna
end on a lighter note.
We're gonna end on a lighter note.
So is it okay to be competitive
and not let your kids beat you in games?
I don't let my kids beat me.
- [Tyler] Me either, nope.
- Nope, nope, nope.
- And my son has this thing he likes to do
when we're racing, he'll run
in front of me to cut me off
and I pushed him down and kept running.
He'll get up crying, he's
like why'd you push me down?
You're cheating!
You're gonna learn the right way, son.
- I know, my daughter does
this like when we're swimming,
we'll do laps and she'll
be like, let's race.
And I'm like, I'm really fast, honey.
Like, I'm a lot bigger than you.
And she will try and go, okay one...
and then she'll jump and
she's supposed to go on three.
And I'm like, and I'll still beat her
and I'm like, that's right!
- Yeah, that's right, in
your face little girl!
- I'm like, you lost!
I don't do that.
Um, but I do think it's important.
Like, 'cause I grew up in
Texas and like in Texas,
like sports, they're like,
you have to learn how to lose.
- Yeah.
- Like you, exactly.
(audience claps)
Like how many times have you lost in life?
Even in the entertainment
industry, oh my God.
I've lost so much, like at certain things.
You have to learn how
to do that gracefully.
- Gracefully, yeah.
My son wasn't having it,
he doesn't like to lose.
- Oh no, neither do
neither one of my children
and I'm like, if you're
gonna throw a tantrum
you better get to your room,
I'm gonna chase you there.
I was like, I can't have that.
Like, you know, whining 'cause you...
I'm like, that's not out a real issue.
- Nope, no, I don't do that either